[Music]
Luke when you're asked to take on a part
that doesn't require a mustache is that
a sacrifice in the way and where is your
mustache right now massive sacrifice I
had to get rid of it for my next movie
and I begged the director and he was
like no I'm sorry it's not okay
but it'll come back as soon as we're
down I'll be growing it back I do love a
good mustache I love it you you rock the
best mustache everyone check out our son
Luke just kills it here thank you so
much Luke thank you very much okay
everyone I'm here with Robin Robin how
you doing today doing all right you
happy to be here I'm so excited to talk
to you uh you're one of my favorite
actresses and one of my favorite things
about your acting though is I feel like
a lot of the movies you're in and shows
you're great at acting sitting down so
can you give any great advice because a
lot of your characters have to sit about
doing that well to me acting all
together whether you're standing or
sitting is about listening and listening
is something that's very comfortable to
do from a seated position but I I think
the role of listening and acting is
maybe an underrated aspect of it I think
if you're listening with attention to to
the other actor that the scene actually
exists here between the two people in
the space between the two people it's
never about one person's um you know
slam dunk performance the way it's
written about
um it's about what's generated between
the two so yeah I I don't have I don't
have an issue with recently being cast
as listeners I mean I certainly in the
past been cast very much as doers
um and the thing I just finished
um I was sort of a a matriarch I mean I
literally have just come back from a
project
um seven months in Bucharest where
um her great gift is as a nurturer and
um
I think that's not celebrated enough
actually in in um in films so happy for
that oh yeah I love that answer and I'm
wondering too so with our sun do you
feel like your character is more of one
of those listener type characters or
something that's more not like that well
I do think that the way she's able to do
good is through listening because every
client is going to have a different set
of needs
um if she were to just come in as an
attorney and impose her views on the
situation and have one fits all sort of
blanket ideas about how divorce should
go she wouldn't be much good and she's
been through this a time or two and one
has the feeling although it's not fully
written in that has been through some
things in her own life that allow her to
have greater perspective on um you know
this trial and I I think her great
contribution is that she's able to say
to Nikki who's in such distress her
client that this too is a privilege this
too is a right
to be allowed to divorce with integrity
and Grace and with the support of the
legal system and the support of your
family and friends is a pretty tall
order and one shouldn't take it for
granted and um that's kind of a
beautiful thing yeah and it's a
beautiful answer and it's exciting I'm
excited people to see this film here and
you're just having a great couple past
years and what stands out for me is
obviously smile I love that film it's so
scary so my question for you is are you
someone who goes back and watches the
Final Cut and were you scared watching
it yeah I mean for my own bits I have to
confess they cracked me up because I I
knew full well what was behind them but
the movie Scared the heck out of me
um and um and I think really really
impressive debut feature by that
incredible director
um they had an incredible PR team too
they came up with uh the the perfect way
to Market this thing I mean I've never
seen anything like it they made things
go viral left and right I mean it was
really a model of its kind and so um but
it would not have worked if Ceci bacon
wasn't so phenomenal in that lead role I
mean she really sold that so yeah and
and you did as well it was so fun to
watch you guys work together in the
great film and I'm excited for people to
see our sun so make sure to check out
Robin absolutely kill it in this film as
well thank you so much Robin thank you
so much Christopher it's so exciting to
see you here at this world premiere of
our sun how does it feel to be at a
world premiere at Tribeca uh super
excited I'm super excited
yeah so I mean like what was your
favorite thing about being a part of
this film any like Memories on set you
could think of
I remember doing this one part scene and
I got to meet like a lot of kids we had
such a fun time actually while doing
wall at a day of filming at uh ice cream
truck came in the back so we could all
get ice cream what's your go-to ice
cream
I love it um and then Christopher what
is like with your acting career it's
already like skyrocketing what's like
your ultimate dream in doing this what
do you want to possibly do one day
but I want to possibly do in my career
I want to be in like a huge comedy
this comedy's like my genre like I love
it
it's very
like if I could be in that definitely am
I any uh specific actors you look up to
right now or like really big fan of our
actresses
I'm
I forgot his name the kid that played
Will Smith in Bel Air the new Bellaire
oh yeah I'm blinking the name but I know
who you're talking about yeah that's a
good one
Christopher thank you so much for
joining me and I can't wait for people
to see you just crushing in this film
thank you so much